hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to be doing
something i've never done
i'm going to be revealing all the
details the address
the trends what's happened with my very
ever first investment property so the
very first house that i ever bought
now the way that it was financed it was
creatively financed i've said this
before my video i was only 17 years old
at the time
so whilst it was a no money down deal
there was still
you know finance that was involved so
you know we had
bank finance on it a mortgage on it the
mortgage outstanding on it
was uh just over a hundred thousand
pounds 101
982 and three pence i bought it for a
hundred thousand pounds it was
then immediately refinanced bought again
the way it was creatively financed
the same day march 24th 2009 i was 17
years old at the time
i'm now 29 years old in my stepdad's
name and the property was
21a maryvale road
bourneville birmingham b32da that was my
first house
and i want to just talk through the
whole figures because when i bought that
house hear this
when i bought that house in 2009 we were
in
a recession everyone was saying to me
don't buy them samuel don't buy it or
the losers
oh samuel no why are you going on these
expensive training courses
i'm going to go to university and spend
40 000 pounds
studying drama you know don't buy a
house
like like that's what they were saying
to me and you don't believe me you don't
believe me
just look at what the newspapers were
saying in 2009 about property they were
saying
you know the market's crashing
properties could drop to 5 000 pounds
they could never recover that's what was
being said
so i'm buying this house my stepdad tim
is helping me out and he's hosting it in
his name you are welcome so i buy it
march 24th 2009
refinance it i've got now a house i've
not paid any money for the house
everyone's going on all but the house is
going to crash that's what i know it's
going to crash i'm thinking well you
know what i don't get
you know i don't care because i'm
renting out this house
for fourteen hundred pounds per month
so i bought this little house normally
down 21a maryville road
check it out i'm renting it out it's
only a three bed house
but there's two reception rooms so what
i do is i turn one reception room into a
bedroom
house so by putting a bed in it what
about planning don't need planning sorry
mr builder
don't need planning what about licensing
don't need a license link
because and you still don't need a
licensing to this day because there's
not
you don't need to license a hmo it's
only got four bedrooms so i just
turned the sitting room into a bedroom
each bedroom rent out
to professional tenants i rent the whole
thing out
in two weeks of buying the house i'm
renting it out
on average each room is renting for 350.
some of them are running for something
more
the single room is going for a little
less i'm making 1400 pounds a month
from my first house now how much profit
is there though it's less than 1400
i've got to pay the mortgage the
mortgage payments of the outstanding
mortgage which was
101 982 pounds and three pence
i'm only paying a measly
166 pounds per month
even to this day i'm paying i'm paying
well it's a bit different now because i
paid the mortgage off but the mortgage
is tiny
the rent is big i've got to pay bills
when i started managing it i was
managing it myself managing it myself i
was making 1 000 pounds
profit from that house when i then
outsourced it and systemized it it was
about 900 pounds so i got my team to do
it
but that that was a normally down deal
so all these people are saying they're
gonna crash
they're gonna crash i'm like i don't
care if it crashes if the house goes
down in value
i'm good i'm making it i'm making a
thousand pounds a month guess what
it's been now almost 12 years since i
bought the house
i've made over 100
000 pounds in rental
cash flow profit 100 grand
so that one house has given me a hundred
thousand pounds
in profit over the last 12 years just
shy of 12 years
but did the house crash though did the
house go down in value
well let's have a look uh no it actually
went up it went down for a short while
but this is what house prices do house
prices go
down up down up but overall over time
they go up
i bought it for 100 000 pounds 2009 it's
now 2020
it's now worth over two hundred thousand
pounds
so i made a hundred thousand pounding
rent and i made a hundred thousand
pounds in cash
in capital appreciation that's how you
get paid in property you get paid
capital appreciation which doesn't pay
the bills and cash flow rent which does
pay the bills
i bought that house in a recession so if
people are saying now if you're looking
to buy a house right now and people are
saying but the house market could crash
you need to say this you just say is it
giving me cash flow though
if it's giving you cash flow you're
gonna hold on to it you're gonna wait
even if you crash it doesn't matter
because it's going to bounce back up
again
in time that's my very first house
bought it when i was 17 years old
since buying it i've moved it over from
my step-dad tim's name
to now my name well it's not even in my
name now now it now it's in
um is it in my name or is it in my
company no it's now held in
lease option agreement properties
because i kind of figured you know what
it's a little bit like a lease option
because technically it wasn't in my name
but i had the option to put it in my
name so it's in lease option agreement
loa properties limited and the property
i tend to be really interested in
sometimes people say to me saying
this property doesn't make sense it says
you paid this much and this much and
that and what's going on
uh land registry i hate to say this
because i love land registry
but they get things so wrong they said
catch this you wouldn't you wouldn't
believe i couldn't make this up
it says on land registry if you check it
out you get the title deeds that i
bought 21 america road
for 185 000 pounds
okay um last year january last year
that figure i don't know where they got
that from because i didn't
i bought it for a 101
982 pounds and three pence which was the
exact amount
as the mortgage outstanding i just paid
off the mortgage and
and that's when i bought it so land
registry um you're very wrong on that
you're also very wrong initially when i
first bought the house
i bought the house for 100 but then the
same day
uh back on the toilet is it used to say
a hundred and 120 on the same day two
figures
the hundred dropped off i then bought it
for 101
in uh january 2019 i bought it for 101
and three pence but it's 185. it's
almost as though land registry were like
i can't believe that you're buying it
that cheap and they just put a different
number on it but
anyway um i've spoken to my sister and
i've got a little verification from them
i've even got a letter from my solicitor
i've got the actual message that they
sent to the land registry and said hey
confirmation from the cause how does
land registry know what's going on while
they hear it from the solicitor so the
solicitor writes the land registry and
says
this is how much a house is sold for
land register you update their systems
so my sister messages land registry
sends them the formal slip and says this
this is who's selling it this is who's
buying it this is the price the android
used to receive that and then put a
different figure on it so
it's absolutely bizarre but when you're
interested in how much a house sold for
and things like that and you go on right
moving you see the sold prices
sometimes they can be wrong so never
trust them with your life
always make sure that you know is the
good deal a good deal for you or is it
not
and the really crazy thing is these
pictures okay of this house
21 a.m over road one bed house share
yeah it's a four bed house but
i understand that it was advertised as
that but look
these pictures these that is not the
kitchen in the house
that is not the living room
that's from a different house that is
actually from my
different house that's from a house i
own down the road i own a house in
persia road and that is the
that is the that is the living room
that's one of the bedrooms from
perschall road
none of these pictures are actually
pictures that are
21am every road but it again it shows
you can't sometimes
trust what it says on the house prices
land registry
sometimes it is just wrong it's wrong
it's not correct
so if you are a land registry expert and
you think you know why that is comment
below i'm really curious as to why land
registry can get things so
drastically wrong i'm not complaining
too much though
because their errors have always been in
my favor
if i buy the house for 100 grand and
then it says that i bought it for 185
all that's going to do is it's going to
make it easier for me to then get
finance against it
the house is now worth approximately
around about two hundred and fifteen
thousand pounds according to estate
agents according to zoopla
and and comparables it's still renting
out really nicely
and i've actually put the house now i've
given the house to
um to the homeless so now got vulnerable
people living in the house
and i've just recently only about three
months ago
uh passed it on and uh i'm still getting
i am still profiting from it i'm still
getting getting rent from it
um but it was just a way really of just
giving back
and that was my very first house it's a
sentimental house that's what i've done
with it so that's the figures 100 grand
in cash flow
100 grand in capital appreciation now
giving back still making profit off it
though which is good
and who knows maybe in another 10 years
it would have doubled again
and be worth 400 000 pounds maybe it
would have gone down
as long as it keeps giving me rent i
don't mind my first day of a house
21 america road thank you to tim for
helping me get it thank you to my
mentors for
teaching me how to buy properties
without using any of my own money and
also thank you to you guys for watching
my videos
and for just believing in me to continue
go to new heights i appreciate you
please do smash the subscribe button
also if you want to see my worst
property investment because it's not all
good
okay you're gonna have properties that
underperform over perform
and perform and many of my properties
have over-performed some of them are
badly underperformed
you want to see some of the properties
that haven't gone too well check out
them check out right here okay that's my
worst house ever
and uh you want to see winners on the
wednesdays people that i've trained and
helped become financially independent
and property check out those stories
right here
and please don't forget to subscribe
down here i'll see you next time thanks
for watching peace out